good morning ladies and gentlemen Greg
Alva here John so after a weekend full
of infinity war talk we are here today
to talk about ant-man and the wasp where
were they
but before we hop into this trailer
reaction people wanted to give a shout
out to today's awesome video sponsor and
that is amino apse ladies and gentlemen
yeah you guys may remember us shouting
out the marvel amino back when we shot
the spider-man homecoming review and
we're excited to be working with these
guys again for those of you who aren't
familiar amino is a mobile network of
communities for both fans and creators
alike that spans pretty much any
conceivable interests you can think of
yeah whether you're a Marvel fan or a
Harry Potter fan if you love Westworld
Riverdale Rick and Morty whatever it is
there's a community of like-minded
passionate people waiting to welcome you
on amino obviously we wind up doing a
lot of Marvel related content here on
the channel and the Marvel amino is an
excellent place for fans and creators to
gather post the reviews and theories
participate in polls share fan art and a
whole lot more
you can browse curated feeds check in
with your communities in real time and
even take advantage of the apps text
voice and avatar chat features to bring
you even closer with the people you meet
on the app and if you're a fan of our
videos it's a great place to keep track
of our various Marvel related content
which will be posting over there with
each new Marvel related to video in
short guys with me know it's easier than
ever to keep up with people all over the
world who share your love and passion
for your favorite fandoms and to
contribute to the conversation you'll
find a link in the description box so
download the app and make sure to follow
us at real rejects all one word and make
sure to check out our post that we made
over there before yeah yeah we've got
some polls going we've got a bunch of
our videos posted it's a lot of fun and
also huge thanks to the folks over at
Amino and without further ado guys check
out that trailer I just sort of happened
[Music]
[Music]
what happened to you that's crazy could
be gold so like walks through walls and
stuff
[Music]
do you remember that's us
[Music]
and the wasp teaming up sexy more
intense
[Music]
back in the corner up okay
[Music]
[Music]
projects called Goliath I like the water
my record 21 feet you 6565 Terri white
dr. bill foster my friend biochemist
yeah he's yeah he had his own comic book
for a little bit meaning he's called
Goliath here I've never even seen the
title of it black Goliath I wonder if
he's gonna show up at all as Goliath in
this movie maybe maybe it's like a
little little moment like an easter egg
hopefully we get a little moment where
he actually does do it he's great at
IMDb as Goliath oh and too much a little
too much all that stuff with the wasp
but I think looks really awesome
she looks badass she looks really badass
I think there's gonna be a clash of who
to follow we and their dynamics and
their partnership like a lot of these
movies involve them learning how to work
together yes everybody wants to be the
leader no it's definitely gonna have
that man and then she's coming in later
on and she's probably gonna be a little
bit more of a leader in this area I
imagine she's frame to honor the
daughter I know this is gonna lead into
Avengers 4 in some fashion because a man
and a wasp or in Avengers 4 but I think
in the comics hope Van Dyne becomes like
a villain named Red Queen and Michelle
Pfeiffer is supposed to be in here as
Janet Van Dyne which is she was lost in
the quantum realm as we know in the
first adman and they said they opened up
the quantum realm and that's how the
character ghost came through this looks
pretty cool ghost looks really cool in
the comics ghost is actually a dude so
they're doing the gender bender yes
right mana sharing or something
today she doesn't matter like all that
phasing stuff that she was doing the
whole time I mean I wish we got a little
bit more nerd they had it was one shot
where she was like oh like she doesn't
understand what her powers are in some
way so I imagine she's not just
full-blown evil just because that one
shot huh but she also seems like she
probably is the main antagonist in this
story or whoever Walton Goggins is
playing because Walton Goggins is
usually a bad dude gonna be fun to have
the crew back to I mean you know they
have Michael Pina especially cracked me
up in the first movie and I was glad to
see like a good amount of his stuff in
this trailer still doing the recapping
of the exposition we'll see what's gonna
go down
he's our English please yeah just for
this movie especially I love what
they're doing and how much further
they're going with you know blowing up
objects around ya freakin objects around
it's not just ant-man on the wasps
they've got like that salt shaker thing
and they're like blowing up buildings
and cars and they seem like they're
having a lot more creativity with their
action and their comedy in this movie it
just looks really exciting because you
do feel the whole team ensemble here it
seems like they're embracing more of the
weirdness yeah of what ant-man is yeah
which which works out with the humorous
tone that they want for these movies
exactly and especially after infinity
war nice to embrace something that seems
a lot more calm and just weird and fun
it is this is just relaxing this is a
relaxing experience you can always have
I'm gonna leap into my popcorn I was
hoping we get some images in Michelle
Pfeiffer she's on the poster and I don't
know if we just missed her in this
trailer but they had this one shot where
a man's in the quantum realm so I
imagine they pull er out of it in some
way yeah Janet Van Dyne in here maybe
she'll show up part way but well the
action looks cool the comedy looks great
this looks like a really fun enjoyable
time I'm excited that we get to get this
home and I'm excited to see how this
will lead into a vendor's forward in
some way hopefully it does alright guys
well thanks for watching you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about to get notified
every time one of our vids is up and you
can check us out on patreon full-length
TV show reactions weekly Q&A is but more
importantly follow us on a me no apps
link in the description box people and
head up them
Illume you know